turn to get this in Teresa what could it
second billion dollars do how many
houses can you use private how many jets
can you own so give the give the rest of
it away but if I were giving money away
I would probably give it mostly to
direct service providers as people
actually or they're actually doing
research they forgive me cancer research
or AIDS research the actual researchers
and the people actually writing on the
ground services to people because
there's plenty of think tanks there's
plenty of things that get a lot of money
to turn a lot of position papers and
some of them are useful position papers
but what tend to be under funded by
private donors today or people give the
services on the ground little things
that aren't sexy soup kitchens you know
food closets things like that those are
desperately underfunded by private
donors to give to the big issues you get
something named after your soul and so
on I think you have money mainly due to
causes like that and something else I I
think I might give away money to
establish writing programs writing
program is especially the inner city but
elsewhere as well in rural areas places
where a lot of times or we could
certainly go to school they don't get
the individual encouragement to think
about the possible you may have the
talent to be a writer let's try that out
and and see me saying that people tend
to write a lot any people think Oh on
and we need more people will think a lot
and I would like to encourage that
hey